you also said not too long ago we
weren't forecasting we said to rate
hikes this year possibility of three so
let's start with what do you have to see
Dennis Lockhart to be on board for the
next rate hike I am safe limited this
way I'm framing my decisions related
let's say april june and thereafter on
four principal criteria first is the
growth numbers and how the growth seems
to be trending most importantly are we
sustaining momentum in terms of growth
the second would be the employment
numbers and i would be using a kind of
threshold of 200,000 of payroll jobs a
month as a good indicator of a
continuing strong jobs picture
employment picture i would say at the
same time that as we move forward if we
continue to make progress in the economy
you would expect naturally that that
jobs number would decline but for the
moment i'm saying two hundred thousand a
month as a kind of threshold number okay
the third aspect would be inflation and
i'm paying particular attention right
now to core inflation and trimmed mean
cuts of inflation to try to understand
the underlying strength of upward price
pressures so that's the third and the
fourth would be inflation expectations
and the direction that inflation
expectations apparently are going or the
explanation for break evens that seem to
be declining well that's been a is that
one of the factors as infancy inflation
expectations getting a lot of attention
from all you fed officials now they sunk
they came back and then they sunk again
in the beginning of the year they were
recovering but your inflation dashboard
the Atlanta Fed has so many cool
indicators 30 inflation indicators on
that dashboard and i believe the last
reading that you mentioned in one of
your speeches suggested that you
it had ebbed a little bit but you but
inflation expectations is one of the
things that was was not in the plus
column I think it had a little bit of a
down arrow well there has been some
retracing of the inflation expectation
numbers as derived from inflation
compensation and securities I still hold
the view that what we saw earlier which
was a deteriorating picture to some
extent was really based on liquidity and
risk premia not fundamental unang kurung
of inflation expectations and my working
assumption continues to be that
inflation expectations are reasonably
well anchored around our two percent
target and the recent retracing is
comforting I don't you know I don't
necessarily think you know problem
solved okay but it's comforting are you
in the camp that says it would be not
only acceptable but even good for
inflation to overshoot its target for a
while because it is under shot for so
long the implication of that seems to me
be more caution and an even longer
period of time before that next interest
rate increase comes well obviously I'd
like us to sort of have a a soft landing
around two percent and then sustain
something around two percent that would
be the ideal world but the is some
overshoot for a limited period of time I
think
considering what other benefits that
might have for the economy could be an
acceptable situation if we get above two
and a half percent I would begin to
start to get a little bit nervous and
let me make another point that's
important because the committee has
reiterated its position that our
attitude toward inflation is symmetric
that is to say we think the cost to the
economy of a shortfall inflation are
equal to the cost to the economy or
similar to the cost of the economy of an
overshoot so we're we're not viewing two
percent as a ceiling and I think that
suggests that some tolerance of
overshooting two percent would be
acceptable